Iran is stepping up enforcement of its
dress code authorities are installing
cameras in public places to crack down
on women who disobey compulsory dress
rules police say those caught breaking
the law will be warned of the
consequences through text message
a growing number of women stopped
covering their hair in protests against
the death of 22 year old Martha amini in
police custody last year
businesses that could not abide by the
head scarf law will be worn first then
they will receive the warning of being
closed and then they will be closed this
warning includes Halls restaurants and
large shopping centers